so Dad he's doing he's doing pretty good
my mom she's
honestly
she's doing really well Todd and Julie
Chrisley adapting to their new reality
much to daughter Savannah's surprise it
sounds crazy for me to say all right
they're doing really well
but they are they're the two most giving
people I think I've ever met in my
entire life Savannah shares new details
about their life behind bars on her
unlocked podcast the day that
we dropped my parents off that was
really tough for starters dad's already
got a job he is working
in the chapel
which is
absolutely amazing and I could never be
more proud of my dad and the man that he
is so Dad he's doing he's doing pretty
good there's days that are tough there's
struggles we get to see him so for that
I am forever grateful meanwhile Julie's
keeping busy with a family pastime
anyone that knows my family knows that
Spades is our thing it gets real intense
we may start an argument here or there
over it oh wait wait I'm about to have a
heart attack over here she's
playing some Spades
and when I tell you playing she is
running a dog on everyone
yeah Mom appears to be thriving she's
made friends she's keeping busy she's
going to church she's
working Todd and Julie are both very
faithful people and I think they're
taking that strength with them to prison
I mean we're in Florida got a beautiful
house
the sunshine state looks a little
different for Todd but his minimum
security facility is known for being one
of the cushiest in the country he is
working
in the chapel no details on Todd's new
salary but ETS learned he can make as
much as 40 cents an hour and there are
plenty of hours in the day lights on is
at 4 45 A.M but over in Kentucky it's 6
a.m for Julie I have two dishwashers
which is a must if you can possibly have
it no must-haves at her new home but in
between card games Julie can take part
in art programs like painting and
sculptures what we will not do is we
will not break
Todd and Julie are serving a combined
19-year sentence from Pensacola to
Lexington the couple's 655 miles apart
God didn't bring us this far to drop us
off the reality stars were convicted for
bank fraud and tax evasion and they have
until February 22nd to file their appeal
I think they're optimistic and let me be
clear I think that optimism is well
placed this trial was riddled with heirs
and we expect the appeals court to see
that and in the meantime it sounds crazy
for me to say all right they're doing
really well
but they are